the things that you want to convey with
your clothing and with your style are
very different than the things that i
want to convey and it becomes really
easy
to see especially older men if you ever
see an older guy that's in like his 50s
and he looks like he's trying to dress
like he's 18 or he's in his mid-20s it's
because his wife is dressing him because
for her being able to signal things like
youth or maintain fertility or
trendiness or relevance those are those
are good from a female perspective but
from a male perspective that makes you
look like you're denying like you
haven't accomplished anything over the
last 20 30 years and so you're still
trying to hold on to all this untested
potential as opposed to no i've earned
some status and i've made some i've made
some moves and i've i've attained a
certain level of credibility and a
certain level of status within my life
and i want to dress in a way that
symbolizes that
welcome to episode 123 of the michaela
peterson podcast in this episode i spoke
with men's style coach author and tedx
speaker tanner guzzy it was interesting
because i feel the focus on men's
fashion has shifted dramatically over
the last few decades and fashion is
something every guy should know about
and don't it's so easy to look good or
at least look better depending on how
you dress
and you get treated so differently if
you put a bit of effort into your
appearance it can be the difference
between getting a job or not or a
relationship
or not or being taken seriously even if
you don't know what you're talking about
it's important and many men don't know
anything about fashion we covered topics
like how personality is expressed
through style choosing suits and shoes
the three archetypes of male fashion
husbands dressing for their wives men
wearing dresses we also went into a bit
of detail about guzzi's personal life
the joys of parenthood and his time
spent as a missionary for the church of
latter-day saints this was a pretty cool
episode i hope you guys enjoy it and
have a good week
[Music]
tanner guzzy welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me on mikael i'm
excited to be here it's nice to see you
again
yeah this should be a fun conversation
before
before we get into it can you give a
brief background about
who you are and what it is you do
yes
so tanner guzzy i am based out of the
salt lake city-ish area uh born and
raised here i am uh a father of five and
i have one of the weirdest jobs in the
world i'm a men's style coach so i teach
guys how to dress better and why they
should even give a crap about what their
clothes are and how they look and how
they present themselves with their
grooming and all of that too
that's good i think that's very
important i think that's very important
i guess i guess we should start off by
why does it matter
how you look
the biggest thing is because it is a
it's a way to express yourself not only
to the world around you but also to
change your own self perception
when it's done right it's just as
powerful as learning how to
to read and write the the ability to
articulate yourself through your
appearance is just as powerful and just
as important as it is to do it with the
written or the spoken language
i think that's fair i think that's
something that's underestimated right
now
about how much it matters and people
care what you look like you're
completely judged right away
yeah and you should be because we're
visual creatures and we can't take in
we can't treat people like they're blank
slates like everything is completely
open and there's no prejudgments or
preconceptions now obviously being
mature means that you take that initial
impression and then you re-evaluate it
based on new information that you get as
you get to know people and you go
through that process as well but our
brains would explode if we didn't have
initial impressions of people based on
how they looked or how they sound or all
these other kind of patterns that we
learn how to recognize yeah what does it
look like when you get started with a
client you go through their wardrobe do
you suggest certain things based on how
they already look
yeah i actually don't do a lot of
suggestions until we get quite a ways
into the program because
i need to figure out who they are how
they see themselves fitting within the
world and what the ideal version of them
looks like how they want to communicate
themselves to the people at work or
their family or dating prospects or any
of those things and so we go through a
pretty detailed process of discovering
all that a lot of it starts with what
they have in their wardrobe
and then after we're done with that
then that's when i start making
recommendations but what's really cool
is most of the time i don't need to make
that many recommendations because my
guys get good enough with this on their
own that they're making really good
decisions by themselves so you get
people to look at an ideal version of
themselves
yeah
okay
that makes sense so are there any style
like complete no's like how do you feel
about bedazzled jeans can anyone make
this look good
well okay here's the thing where it gets
really interesting and i guess we can
continue to compare it to language or
articulation is
that you think about some of those
things like bedazzled jeans or crocs or
really baggy cargo shorts or that kind
of stuff and right and that's almost the
equivalent of of your swear words where
there are very few times when it's
appropriate to do it but when it is it's
really appropriate to do it but most of
us overly rely on that kind of language
and too many men overly rely on those
types of clothes and so you need to be
yeah you need to be more specific with
how you do it how do you feel about
birkenstocks
perks honestly man there are some guys
especially when when you're in kind of a
coastal area they can be a really cool
kind of a beach look or you can get a
little kind of like new england wasp to
it or something else and so i think
berks when they're done in the right
context can end up looking pretty cool
okay okay what what kind of person
does does every man need a good suit
what does a good suit look like how does
somebody tell when they're wearing a
good suit
okay there's a lot of questions in that
one no not every man needs a good suit
anymore which sucks because suiting used
to be something that was kind of
ubiquitous and people really understood
that when you were if you were
participating in western civilization if
you were doing something that you wanted
to communicate dignity and respect and
self-mastery any sort of credibility or
authority you would wear a suit yeah but
we've not only
moved away from the idea of hierarchies
in general but we've also kind of split
from rather being this big kind of
homogeneous western culture
into being a bunch of smaller tribes and
you get different cultures based on the
industry that you work in or based on
the music that you listen to or what
your political ideology is or even you
know simple things like are you an apple
or an android guy and all this other
kind of stuff and so we've moved away
from this homogenous culture into
something that's a lot more
tribe specific and in so many of those
wearing a suit is actually a big sign of
being an outside an outsider and so it
makes you it actually comes with more
reliability than with more advantages to
it
wow
wow okay wild right
yeah i mean you look at
movies and videos of things in the 50s
and everybody looked
i feel like people look better than they
look now
and there's an aesthetic component that
we miss for sure and obviously the suit
isn't the only way to do it because you
go back 300 years and people looked good
and healthy and strong and men looked
like men and women looked like women and
it wasn't suits like we see it today or
you go back to you know ancient aztec
culture or the romans or
you know the aborigines or anybody else
and we've always used clothing and
there's always been an aesthetic
component to it and sadly
for so many of the these micro tribes
that we're in we're kind of caught up in
this
post-modernism where we reject beauty we
reject aesthetics and in order to be
able to
signal that you're part of the group
that you understand the language
you have to embrace a level of ugliness
and it sucks
yeah
do you think that's because people
i've been torn about this i assume
that's because
the general population has gotten more
unhealthy so just we've gotten uglier as
a whole so it's like why not embrace it
like potentially the fat acceptance
movement is because people can't figure
out how to lose weight they don't
understand that what they eat matters
can't lose weight so why not make it an
acceptance movement movement if you
can't figure out how to change it
yeah i agree with that and it's not even
i don't think acceptance is is correct
with how far it's gotten they call it
fat acceptance but it's really this like
we're going to reject beauty we're going
to reject goodness we're going to reject
health so that you don't reject us it's
almost like um
like the the aesop's sour grapes fables
of you know i just don't want those
lower or those higher grapes because
they're probably sour anyway or it's
eminem in eight mile you know rapping
about all of his weaknesses so that in
that rap battle the guy can't actually
get anything else on him it's this
complete rejection of of these
traditional standards and if you if i
reject you first you can't reject me you
know you can't fire me i quit type of
thing
oh
that could be it
yeah they shut down didn't they shut
down victoria's secrets this year
victoria's secret the runway show did
you hear about that yeah yeah and they
started doing again you've got all this
uh these kind of like anti-beauty beauty
standards where it's all about we're
embracing all people at all size and all
and i get it i mean body acceptance is
wonderful when you look at things like
uh you look at people who come back from
war and they're missing limbs or burn
victims or other things that really are
it's out of your control you're born a
certain way in and that and honestly
even if you are if you're if you're fat
and you can't control it it doesn't mean
you don't have any value as a person but
you're missing out on
not only communicating your full value
but experiencing your full value if you
don't try and make yourself healthy and
also in some way aesthetically valid if
you don't try and make yourself
beautiful as a woman or handsome as a
man you miss out on what your full
potential is
yes
people react to you differently too like
even when i got healthy and i lost
weight people reacted to me differently
dramatically or i have blonde hair right
now and my hair is not naturally blonde
i get a completely different reaction
being blonde
right yeah and you're the same person
but do you also see yourself differently
does your self-perception change a
little bit when you see yourself in the
mirror compared to before you were
blonde or when you were bigger
oh definitely
right it's huge yeah it's huge
okay
what tips do you have for people if they
want to get started so say
say that they've been focused on work or
family and
i wouldn't i don't want to say like let
things go but just haven't prioritized
how they look how do you suggest people
get started or make it a higher priority
i would say the first thing to do for
most men
is
go through your closet and throw out
anything that has any sort of a graphic
print on it because
you should not be basing your identity
based on whatever product it is that you
consume or you should not be looking so
apathetic that you're still wearing the
t-shirt that your company hosted a 5k
and you just got the t-shirt for free
when you showed up to work that day like
you should be projecting yourself as
more than that and so get rid of
anything that has any graphics on it and
then from there start to focus on
pay attention to people around you pay
attention to those that look like they
are
that they're credible that they're
successful that they're happy that
they're authoritative that they're
dignified whatever the virtues are
that are the things that you want to
emulate pay attention to the people
around you and look at people who look
like they express those things
and then start to emulate what those
styles are especially because it's
different it's different in toronto than
it is in salt lake which is different
than nashville and it's different if you
work in tech versus if you're in a blue
collar industry and so there's not any
specific
like just this one technical thing you
can do just like you can't say
you know learn how to use these words if
you speak french or if you speak english
or you speak german because the words
all mean something different so you have
to focus on what's the meaning you want
to convey and how are the people in your
world conveying that same meaning and
start to emulate it from there does that
make sense that does make sense that
does make sense
yeah look at what you're trying to
convey look at people who are doing what
you're trying to convey
yeah yeah that's smart
okay hair
do you have hair tip styles or does that
completely differ for people as well
facial hair is a little bit what's in
right now right there's a lot of man
well
and again right no you're good i love
that question because it comes down to
again like we don't have this this kind
of homogeneous culture same thing with
like what are the trends that are coming
down the pike and i don't know it
depends are you do you are you into
sports and what kind of sports are you
into are you in this industry or that
industry but hair is different because
hair and
and beards are different because you
actually have limitations if you don't
have a good set a good head of hair if
you're starting to really lose it
honestly just shave it and embrace the
bald look there aren't very many
masculine ways to have a receding
hairline that looks good on you same
thing if you've got a patchy beard that
come that doesn't come in great sorry
with the way most of the world is right
now you can't do a goatee without
looking like you're holding on to the
90s and so you're better off either
doing clean shaven or doing a full thing
but a lot of it is going to be dependent
on
on what your actual genetics and what
your health markers are but what a lot
of guys really should be doing is
using their grooming their hair their
beard
even their physique or their posture
their body language yeah as a way to
kind of counter signal a lot of what
they're doing with their clothing
because what most men do is they get
really one dimensional with their
appearance it's i'm i'm you know you go
back to the high school stereotypes of
i'm a jock and so everything about me
looks like the jock or i'm a nerd and so
everything about me looks like a nerd
and a fully established adult man should
be multi-dimensional and so you should
be able to look really clean in a suit
but maybe you've got a beard and long
hair and so it's like oh this is a
little bit more interesting because he
isn't so perfectly polished or maybe
you've got you know a really big build
because you're strong and you've taken
good good care of yourself in the gym
and and so you dress in a way that's a
little bit more friendly and inviting
instead of intimidating or you have some
fat and some weight to lose and so you
dress in a way that counter signals that
yes i still am disciplined and i'm
dignified and i still pay attention to
the details even if my physique isn't
exactly where i want it to be either but
create some multi-dimensionality between
all of these aspects of how you present
yourself to people
when you're trying to give people style
advice do you also work on physique and
diet and lifestyle
i usually partner up with other coaches
to kind of point them towards that and a
lot of times most of my clients are guys
who come in and they're already halfway
through that journey they see the value
of it and that's when they decide they
want to start working on the clothing
aspect of it too
okay but yeah it's a huge aspect
honestly the biggest thing that you can
do to improve your appearance has
nothing to do with clothes it's getting
better shape that that's the biggest
thing you could do yeah you see people
at fashion shows and they're wearing
curtains right like it just looks
terrible and like oh no that was unique
stylish like no that person was hot
yeah yeah
exactly yeah do you find that
men are dressing less masculine and are
we just headed continually heading in
that direction because i've seen like
people are showing up in dresses now i'm
not sure how i feel about that i don't
think i feel good about it i'm open
though like do whatever but i don't find
it attractive but like what's going on
there
yeah i think we're seeing two different
movements you're seeing this move
towards androgyny and that's where you
get a lot of the dresses you get a lot
of the high fashion you get a lot of
kind of the urbanites and it's almost
along kind of political or ideological
lines where this idea of androgyny in
men or women are interchangeable and
there's not there not that many
differences
and then at the same time on the other
hand you get this kind of like
anti-aesthetic aesthetic of you're going
to have to pry my cargo shorts and my
80s metal t-shirt and my combat boots
out of my cold dead hands because
there's no way i'm ever going to wear
anything besides that
oh yeah
neither neither of those are ideal
exactly and both of them become
kind of
caricatures of of what they really could
be or should be and we've rejected the
idea of there being a deliberate and
intentional and at the same time
masculine way to dress because we either
reject masculinity and embrace fashion
or embrace trends or embrace androgyny
or we reject aesthetics and embrace
masculinity but we treat both of these
as if they're mutually exclusive and
they're not
how did you get started doing this
man i
so the early the early story of it is i
went to a private school when i was
seventh eighth grade sixth grade stuff
like that had to wear the gray dress
slacks the white shirt the rep stripe
tie the navy blazer the whole thing
i was really really this was like
mid-90s i was really big into punk rock
and bmx bikes and snowboards and all of
that and so i wanted green liberty
spikes and i wanted battle jackets
right like just the complete opposite as
far as an aesthetic and especially you
go back to like the 90s gutter punk and
it was very in your face
and i couldn't wear that when i was in
school or my friends that were my
friends that i would ride bikes with
would see me come home from school and
they would make fun of me because i was
wearing my private school clothes and so
i learned
from experience pretty early on how much
appearance has to do with identity and
how much it has to do with shaping your
own sense of who you are and also how
people perceive you
and then that was something that was
kind of in my pocket for a long time i
dealt with it when i was serving as a
missionary for my church in toronto
actually so kind of in your home your
hometown and uh had to wear a suit and a
tie all the time and the way people
perceive me there and so
about 10 years ago i realized that i was
interested in it i wanted to write about
something i was sick about writing about
politics or anything and so i started a
little blog called masculine style and
it's picked up momentum and here we are
10 years later and i get to do this full
time
that's very cool okay can we talk about
missionary work you're comfortable yeah
absolutely okay so yeah yeah absolutely
give me a background on that we'll take
this conversation in a slightly
different direction what brought you to
toronto and what were what were you
doing exactly
yeah so i'm a member of the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints
and what we do is for young men you have
a commitment where you go out and you
serve a full-time mission for two years
i'm sure you've seen the guys with like
the black name tags on their chests
they're wearing the white shirts and the
suits and all that yep
so you go do that for two years uh when
i went you went when you were 19 now
they have guys go a little bit younger
but
you don't get to pick where you go nor
do you get to pick the language that you
speak you just open up an envelope that
says this is where you're going and when
you leave and when you come back and
here's the language you're speaking wow
okay yeah that's interesting so i got it
that's pretty good then that could have
been weird
right well and i have you know i have
one of my brothers served in the czech
republic another one was supposed to
serve in haiti but because of the unrest
there he ended up going to fort
lauderdale florida i have cousins that
hate here
okay exactly right but i mean i've had
cousins that have served in like the
sticks of panama or people that have
been in russia like you really can go
kind of anywhere almost to the point
where i remember being a little bit
disappointed that i was going to canada
because all of your friends go to all
these exotic places and they get to do
it in a whole different way but i had to
speak spanish which helped it helped
kind of make it feel a little bit
different and i fell in love with the
city and i fell in love with
with being able to learn how to express
myself in spanish and it was it was a
hard two years for sure i mean
you uh you're doing it full time you're
not dating you're not going not going to
school you're not working uh when i was
out
i got two phone calls a year with my
family i'd call them on christmas and on
mother's day and other than that it was
emails once a week and you were in the
trenches like it's it's a full-on monk
mode right of passage and you're talking
to people about religion and you're
trying to help them see
what religion is and what a relationship
with god and christ can be and to
hopefully join the join the church and
it's it's intense
yeah and i feel like people in toronto
also aren't particularly religious
yeah we dealt with uh i couldn't tell
most the time if people hated me more
for being a latter-day saint or for
being an american but we deal with a lot
of resentment from a lot of people wow
at 19 that's pretty yeah that's
interesting that's interesting it's so
good for you i can't wait for my son to
go do it it's just it's so good for you
because you learn how you learn how to
do hard things you learn how to deal
with social pressure and apprehension
you learn how to deal with discipline
you learn how to deal with
it it's so good for you in so many ways
it's got to be scary you learn how to
deal with people who don't want to talk
to you that's scary oh yeah i mean
imagine going and sitting down by
somebody on the bus and you know they
don't want to talk to you because they
recognize the name tag and they know
what you're all about and then trying to
speak to them in spanish or some
language that you started learning five
weeks ago it's terrifying and it's so
good for you because it's so terrifying
oh wow that's intense yeah okay well
that makes sense and you said they do it
earlier now how do you make money yeah
they said you get like an amount of
money you get a year or something to
survive you actually you you pay to do
it what yeah yeah
wow
yeah okay well now i know
okay do you do you
talk about style archetypes at all
i do yeah in fact i have three that i
break it down to go through those let's
get into those yeah okay this is really
good because the archetypes really help
people to understand
i think one of the big mistakes that
that we currently make is that we see
style as something that
creative people whether that's designers
or the people at magazines or
influencers something else that they
create and then we adopt and you know
it's kind of like the fight club like
you're not your khakis type of thing but
what style really is is you start with
who you are on the inside and then you
express that externally through your
clothing so it starts inside and moves
out as opposed to starting outside and
moving in and in order to do that
correctly you have to identify where you
fall within these particular archetypes
and i work with three of them so you've
got rugged refined and rakish really
easy to remember the three r's and what
this is
is
how you interact with the world around
you so the guys who are primarily rugged
they interact with the world through
physical means and it may be kind of the
stereotypical association of like the
lumberjack or the blue collar worker or
the cowboy or it may be somebody who's
more just like a musician or a
triathlete or somebody that still
engages in the world physically and
their happiest when they're doing things
physically and so you start to dress in
a way that expresses that
the refined guys
are guys who understand systems and
hierarchies and social pecking orders
and all of that and they thrive
by
being able to play by the rules climb
the ladder get on the good side of the
boss network the right way and they're
really good at understanding and
following the rules and that's how they
can kind of thrive within society and
you dress in a way that reflects that as
well and then the rakish guys they
understand that hierarchy just as well
as the refined guys but they thrive by
going against it by throwing a big
middle finger to it and rejecting it and
so they dress in a way that reflects
that as well and it's fun as you start
to see these different archetypes and
everybody has all three of them but you
also get them in different ratios you
know most guys will be primarily one
or even two more so than all three but
as you start to dress in a way that
reflects those in the proper ratios
you feel incredibly congruent and
authentic in what your style is because
it feels like you know when you see
yourself in the mirror
what you see actually looks like how you
feel as opposed to there being this
dissonance between the two of them
yeah yeah i feel that okay
yeah one one comment when i got healthy
that's how i felt i can remember looking
right yeah i remember looking in the
mirror
before i got really sick and being like
well i look better than i feel
and then it started to like even the
playing field i was like oh no i'm
looking kind of how i feel uh and then
yeah things things weren't so good okay
this rakish style so how do you go how
do you go against what other people are
doing and still end up stylish what's an
example
it depends on what your tribe is because
you know if you live in the suburbs of
utah and most the guys around me in my
neighborhood they work in the tech
industry so they're wearing just kind of
plain t-shirts and they're they've got
shortly cropped hair and they're wearing
simple skinny jeans and and t-shirts or
and sneakers even for me just having
longer hair and having a fuller beard
and looking like i pay more attention to
my style looks more rakish you get into
urban environments and you get a lot of
like street wear and the sneaker heads
and that kind of stuff and that's
incredibly rakish you can go into more
of a rock and roll type style that you
would see um depending on the decade
whether it's like the beatles were
rakish because of the way that they
dress you certainly can get into punk
rock or metal or a lot of the stuff that
guys will wear when they're doing music
videos or they're on stage and that's
rakish and honestly even if it were
something as simple as everybody in your
office wore a white shirt and you showed
up to work wearing a blue one that's
rakish in and of itself too so it has a
lot more to do with a comparison to the
people around you than there being any
objective standard of what rakishness is
okay say you're that makes sense say
you're trying to hide a part of you like
make one area bigger one area smaller or
you're bigger than you want to be and
you want to be slimmer
let's let's start with that one if
you're bigger than you want to be and
you want to appear slimmer what are this
what style advice do you have for those
guys
we're talking about hiding yourself and
all that just like from a fear a pure
physical component not like my presence
is bigger but my body is bigger and i
want to physically just physical
gotcha okay a couple of easy ways to do
that and a lot of this i'm sure you know
because the the same rules kind of apply
to women you wear solids and dark colors
you have minimal
transition between what you look like on
top and what you look like on the bottom
so if you're doing a more monochromatic
look that helps vertical stripes can do
a lot of good where it draws people's
eyes in and draws them up so that they
can kind of slim you out there
and then for a lot of men
um especially because most of us when
we're bigger than we want to be we tend
to carry more weight in our stomachs and
in our love handles and kind of right
there through the midsection and so what
you want to do is you want to find
shirts that they fit nice and snug in
the chest and the traps the shoulders
and the upper arms so it almost looks
like you're so jacked that you're kind
of nice and snug through there but then
it's a little bit looser with a little
bit more drape down through the waist
and through the seat kind of in that
midsection area because one it hides
that and then two it also draws all this
visible attention to your shoulders and
your upper body instead and so it
artificially creates that v shape that
that's the most masculine aesthetic and
that most of us are after
okay that's good how do you feel about
square toed shoes
i'm so glad that trend is dead that one
is so bad
it's there's there's nothing aesthetic
about it they were just ugly and they
were a trend a certain oh i'm so glad
they're gone
okay that's kind of how i feel
that's one of those like one of the few
four-letter words in the aesthetic world
that that's yeah you just don't ever say
you don't ever say four square-toned
shoes you there's there's no excuse that
makes those work i mean yeah maybe you
go back
25 years ago and
and they would have worked them because
that was what was expected but they're
terrible if you own them get rid of them
today
okay i'm glad i'm glad you brought that
up uh so crocs well how do you feel
about those sandals that are super
strappy those have got to go too right
the ones that you have
straps just i feel like they're called i
just know them because my dad used to
wear them all the time and like the
haraches oh no i feel like i went into
an area that you like i don't know what
a haracha is what's apracha they're kind
of like they're made i think they're
made in southern mexico
um or like uh central america upper
south america but they've got a bunch of
different straps all over them
and those if you're in the right
environment kind of like birkenstocks
can end up being really cool
but
they're tough to pull off in the right
way i gotta i gotta find photos of what
your dad used to wear so that i can i
can tell him if he's doing a good job
with them or not they were pretty bad i
think they were closed-toed but they
just had a lot of straps
anyway
uh
so you'd put the strappy sandals in the
same category as birkenstocks
no the the horaces same thing with like
espadrilles do you remember toms when
those were really big ten years ago yeah
yeah those are in espadrille and those
have like a classic spanish origin where
it's almost like a slipper with the rope
sole and if you're in a coastal area and
it's summer you can do those and do them
really well you know if you're
if you're in florida or you're in spain
or ibiza or you know like you've got a
lot of different options you can do
stuff like that and those
birkenstocks barrages espadrilles way
better than most flip-flops
okay that's fair that's fair um what
recommendations do you have for people
who are i know this is gonna differ
depending on where the person's located
but if you're trying to impress somebody
on a date and exude confidence
what kind of outfit goes with that
so the biggest thing that i would say is
wear something obviously it needs to be
you know context appropriate for what it
is that you're doing on the date and
where you live time time of year and all
of that but the biggest thing that i
would say
is wear something that makes you feel
like
you're on fire makes you feel like
you're the best version of yourself
sadly what a lot of men do
is when they're getting ready to go out
on date they put on something that
part of their brain goes this looks good
and i should feel good in it but then
the other part feels really
self-conscious am i trying too hard does
this not fit right is am i you know is
this too
ostentatious am i am i calling for too
much attention and so they have this
internal battle that's happening
subconsciously the whole time
and remove that don't wear something a
date is the wrong time to experiment
with something new you should already be
really comfortable in what you're
wearing so that it almost feels like
you're putting on
a social version or an aesthetic version
of what your battle armor is so that you
can go in and you can be totally
mentally and emotionally freed up to
focus on what you're doing on the date
as opposed to that nagging in the back
your head the whole time that you're out
there
okay that makes sense uh have you seen
what kind of different style can make to
somebody's love life
like have you seen somebody
without like losing weight say with just
changing how they dress have you seen
what difference that can make
it's massive especially for for married
men um i mean it's huge for guys that
are in the dating market a lot of my
clients are kind of young guys that work
in the tech space and
for them to not only see themselves as
now multi-dimensional but actually carry
themselves with some level of confidence
it makes dating so much easier but
especially for men that are married and
they've been in a relationship for a
long time because
your wife doesn't want to dress you she
doesn't want to see you as another one
of the kids that she has to now think
about this and she has to choose your
clothes i mean it's so emasculating and
it kills the respect that she can have
for you she wants you to look good and
that's why she chooses to dress you
because dressing you is better than you
looking like garbage but what's even
better is if you can dress yourself in a
way that looks attractive and it looks
dignified and it looks self-respecting
and she knows that who she knows on the
inside this person that she's in love
with this person that she's spent all
these years with that that's what she
sees when she sees you know she posts
you up on social media or that's what
she sees when you guys go do family
photos for that year or whatever it is
that you kind of get these versions of
it that she's proud to have you to be on
your arm when you go out on a date or
when you go out you know with friends in
the neighborhood or you go grab drinks
and she's not embarrassed that you're
saying it changes her whole perception
of you your respectability your own
sense of self and it it's it's massive
okay that was good so no square toads
shoes
no square till we just go back to them
yeah
i think that that's that's really
important because i have friends too
that will help their significant other
to dress but it's entirely because
they're like you cannot wear that you
cannot wear that and be seen with me
wear this instead but that's a pretty
low bar you're like aiming for something
a bit higher up
exactly well and a big part of it too is
that
women and men have different aesthetic
goals
when we get dressed the things that you
want to convey with your clothing and
with your style are very different than
the things that i want to convey and it
becomes really easy
to see especially older men if you ever
see an older guy that's in like his 50s
and he looks like he's trying to dress
like he's 18 or he's in his mid-20s it's
because his wife is dressing him because
for her being able to signal things like
youth or maintain fertility or
trendiness or relevance those are those
are good from a female perspective but
from a male perspective that makes you
look like you're denying like you
haven't accomplished anything over the
last 20 30 years and so you're still
trying to hold on to all this untested
potential as opposed to no i've earned
some status and i've made some i've made
some moves and i've i've attained a
certain level of credibility and a
certain level of status within my life
and i want to dress in a way that
symbolizes that and so that's one of the
biggest differences in the way that men
and women dress and another reason why
you shouldn't let most women dress you
oh that's really good advice
do you think there's a way for people
who are younger so say you're younger at
a job is there a benefit in dressing
like some of the older people
only if you've earned some level of
status uh this is why you can get
i'm gonna pick on these guys because
it's so obvious but you get like the
college republicans that they dress up
in their suits and they just look they
just look so dorky in the way that they
do it and it's because there's this
disparity between how young and untested
how
they don't have any credibility they
don't have any experience they don't
have any mastery but the suit still
because we as a culture are not so far
removed that it doesn't have any
symbolism to us to us it still
represents that and so it's it's
basically i'm relying on my clothing to
signal something that i that isn't
actually consistent with who i am and so
the easiest way
for young guys to be able to dress well
in a work environment
is to not dress up more formally or to
not emulate the guys that are at the
absolute like top of the echelon but
dress like everybody else that's in your
same kind of tier but make sure your
stuff fits better focus on simpler
colors
and make sure that you buy higher
quality versions of it because even
though people won't be able to quantify
the difference between like a twenty
dollar shirt that you picked up at a
department store and a hundred dollar
custom shirt
you they will see the difference even if
they can't pinpoint what it is and you
will you will be seen as somebody who
still is young and understands his
position but has potential and is and is
doing more than everybody else around
him and so becomes this very subtle way
of communicating that to the to the
people at work ah okay so be more subtle
high quality okay that's good advice
how much do people
how do you do this on a lower budget how
do you look good on a lower budget
um the biggest thing is it's still
possible but you just have to focus on
keeping things simple and keeping things
that fit will fit well while still
sending the right signals depending on
where you are and what you do a lot of
guys
okay one of the biggest mistakes that
beginners make when they start trying to
dress better is
they associate dressing better with
dressing more formally so you know if
everybody at work is in jeans and a
t-shirt then i'm going to show up in
slacks in a button-up shirt you don't
dress more formally you stay at the same
level formality as everybody else
they focus a lot on color where it's i
have to have all this new color to be
able to bring in because then i stand
out and i look different or they focus
on pattern um which is you know i
the number of guys who i know that
resent the idea of wearing just like a
plain white or a plain blue shirt to
work whether that's a t-shirt or a polo
or a button shirt they hate it because
then that feels so conformist it feels
so
small and so they end up wearing a
patterned shirt and they don't ever pay
attention and look around them and
realize that everybody else is also
wearing patterned shirts because they're
trying to stand out
and so ignore ignore formality ignore
color ignore pattern focus on fit
focus on quality to the best that you
can afford
and then focus on simplicity because you
want your clothing to be
you want it to be the frame of the
painting and you're the painting itself
you're what people are paying attention
to whereas too many guys become the
mannequin for the clothing and they're
all about showcasing the clothes instead
of it going the right way
okay what are your favorite
uh for lack of a better term lower end
cheaper clothing brands
okay
so here in the states um honestly you
can do pretty well even if you go shop
at somewhere like target um they're good
fellow and co uh they're like kind of
houseline they do a pretty good job as
far as fit and keeping things simple and
keeping things relevant without either
being too trendy or too uh too outdated
they do a good job
um if you're younger then you can have
some luck at h m but it's really hard to
avoid all the kind of crazy out there
egregious stuff and then same thing with
places like zara where avoid like the
hyper skinny fits or the really
ostentatious stuff but you can find you
can find good looking stuff at those
places and do it for relatively cheap
i'm also
like
take advantage of outlets go to the j
crew outlet go to banana republic outlet
go to go to the polo outlet and uh and
you can do really well
on on a pretty good budget with brands
like that too okay what about shoes
shoes you can't do it cheap and do it
well you got to invest in it it's worth
it because not only is it good from an
aesthetic perspective because cheap
shoes look cheap and it's really
apparent to anybody who knows what
they're paying attention to but it's
terrible from a health perspective
you're going to kill your you're going
to kill your posture you're going to
kill the way your arches are your feet
are going to get too too cramped in that
that can start to lead to you know ankle
issues or knee issues or back problems
or anything else and so shoes are one of
those things that it's not worth going
cheap on invest that they invest in the
best you can afford with those go
cheaper on pants and shirts if that
means buying higher quality shoes okay
what about accessories
man accessories okay totally different
with men because with women
you can buy accessories purely for the
sake of aesthetics does it look good
does it make me look beautiful does it
make me look does it make me look better
for men we don't have that way of doing
it accessories have to have
some sort of meaning to them you can't
just like pick them up on the impulse
aisle as you're getting ready to check
out that at checkout of the store it has
to have some sort of meaning or
symbolism to it okay
does that make sense yeah it does so it
has to have a use
right right well not even necessarily
like a like a functional use but it can
be something like
um you know maybe you get yourself maybe
get yourself a good watch or a
particular bracelet or a necklace or
something else to commemorate a big
milestone you know i'm about to hit five
years of being self-employed and so i'm
looking at good rolexes for me to be
able to kind of have that as something
that i can celebrate that way um so if
it commemorates something that you've
done uh if it's something that you
picked up on travel that's a that's a
really good reason to have an accessory
where you know it's kind of telling a
story that hey i picked this up while i
was surfing in costa rica or i did this
as part of you know a trip to the
mediterranean or whatever else if
there's a story that's associated with
it um if there's some sort of family
history to it where you know these are
the cufflinks that my grandpa wore at
his wedding and i got them at my wedding
and i can wear them now or if you inject
some sort of symbolism to it like i've
got a big signet ring that has a lot of
religious significance to it and so
anything that has some sort of like
religious or philosophical symbolism um
that when you see it reminds you of
something then you can get away with
wearing accessories that way so it has
to have some sort of either physical
social or psychological purpose in order
to pull off something like a bracelet a
necklace or ring or something else okay
so seashell necklaces
welcome back to 1998. yes
i mean again if you're you know if
you're if you're doing a search for surf
tour down in jamaica and you happen to
be living there for the next eight weeks
or eight months because you're a digital
nomad by all means embrace it make it
part of your style when you go back to
wherever it is that you are but don't
just pick them up because that's what
you see on somebody's instagram feed and
you think it looks cool it has to have
more meaning to it than that for you
okay got it uh what about favorite
high-end brands what are the best of the
best and which ones are are expensive
but no good
oh okay so for the most part expensive
but no good is really the couture brands
um where you're buying
you're buying status without it really
coming in as far as quality so stuff
like gucci or louis vuitton or any of
this
this stuff and i mean a lot of it sure
it can be decent from a quality
perspective but again what you're doing
is you are you're swapping your identity
from being something that's self-created
and self-made into my identity is based
on my consumption of this particular
product
that you have to see my gucci belts or
my mule loafers or you have to see you
know my tom ford sunglasses and that's
that's how you know that i'm a
worthwhile person is because i'm
attaching myself to this particular
brand and so you want more subtlety in
the luxury that you're buying
and so that's going to be though
right and i mean again if you're getting
rakish with some stuff there's ways to
do it right there are ways to be able to
play it right but for most guys
they overly rely on this where it's just
they don't have anything else going for
them and so they try to create an
identity based on this the stuff that
they're buying or wearing or consuming
so there are ways to do it but but not
necessarily the biggest trick to this
even if it's not necessarily high end
because it depends i mean
200 for a suit is not high-end but 200
for a decent t-shirt is pretty dang
high-end it so it depends on what you're
buying and what it is that you're in but
what i what i recommend most guys get
familiar with this is one of the
benefits of the time that we live in now
you go to a department store like a
macy's or a nordstrom or even like a
jcpenney or a kohl's or a dillards or
something else and they have to appeal
to as many people as possible in order
to make in order to be profitable
because they're they're focused on a
particular like actual physical
storefront and what the people are that
come in and buy from them
internet changed everything with that
with online brands
you can have brands that cater to a very
specific body type or a very specific
aesthetic or a very specific uh desire
for it being you know made in the usa or
it's untreated cotton or all these other
things because now they can sell to a
global market and so they can actually
still be profitable without being
limited to what the geography is and so
the biggest thing is to find the brands
that work for you based on the signals
that you want to send based on what
works for your body
and then be really loyal to those brands
so that you can go out and continue to
buy stuff and support them and then the
stuff's going to look really good on you
so like for me one of my favorite brands
is a company called buck mason they're
based out of california
and
i love the fit on their stuff it fits me
perfectly i love the way that it feels
uh the quality of it is really good and
the price point is enough that it feels
premium but it also doesn't feel like uh
you know i gotta save up to to get
something from these guys and so it
checks all these boxes for me really
well and what's cool is that that's all
subjective for every man and it's worth
it to find out what the brands are uh
that it's worth being loyal to in that
regard
okay
and then
so you talked about
gucci and how some people overdo it on
that just for status
is that different when you're buying
something like the rolex watch because
it's not a main piece
how does how do you differentiate
between when it's status seeking or not
good question i like that okay so i
would say that there's two things to
that
the first one yeah i think you're
totally right that it depends on how
much attention it draws
okay because if it's a giant t-shirt
that's just you know almost crassly
blaring it in your face that's very
different than being something that's a
little bit subtle i think that's why
gucci loafers or something can be a
little bit more so because they're in a
little bit more subtle location
and then the other thing too
has to do with
oh man michaela there's so many things
that go into this okay
because part of it has to do with your
archetypes the more rakish you are then
the more you can the more you can kind
of command that that attention and the
more you can do it that way uh the
higher your status is within either your
respective tribe or just kind of society
in general the more you can get away
with i always use conor mcgregor as a
good example of this where he can wear
this kind of stuff
because
it's actually this like giant middle
finger go to hell attitude to what the
mma community used to be where it was
all like the tap out stuff and and the
affliction stuff when he comes in
wearing couture stuff or wearing
well-fitted suits that have these big
patterns and but he could only do it
because he was he's good enough as a
fighter that he can back it up some kid
that's just brand new and isn't winning
any bouts he's not he's not actually
winning any fights if he dresses like
that it's a joke so your relative
mastery your status within a particular
organization comes into play there too
and then the other thing to factor in is
even like rolex for an example
is how much of a status signal is
something within a particular tribe
versus within society in general because
i mean if you show up with a submariner
like a really big flashy rolex
most people are going to recognize that
for what it is but you show up with the
one i'm looking at is like a 1984
uh blue dial datejust
and for most people that i'm around
they're never even gonna know what it is
but to the people that are in kind of
like my menswear tribe or my
entrepreneurial tribe they're gonna
recognize it for what it is and they're
going to going to be able to appreciate
it in a different way so there's all
these little things that come into play
with it and it can sound really complex
and complicated but again it's the same
thing with language where
you learn what jargon you can use i mean
we see this on different uh online
communities and how
uh your your different nomenclature
these words mean this or those words
mean that and and it's almost this kind
of like intra tribal in order to bring
people in and we communicate between us
and at the same time exclude the people
that aren't like us yeah it kind of
serves both of these functions and so a
lot of clothing accessories all of that
has those same those same functions too
okay
that makes sense
that's all good um what are your you can
even see that historically where um like
the whole idea of you don't wear white
um except between memorial day and labor
day yeah that was just to separate old
money from new money where the new money
didn't get those rules and so it was a
way for the old money to be able to like
exclude them same thing with um you
don't wear black you don't mix black and
brown with formal wear that was a
british aristocracy thing that when you
were out in your country house you were
brown and when you were in the city you
were black and so it was really crass to
mix the two of them because it was
indicative of the fact that you didn't
have a country estate that you could you
could go to you didn't understand these
social nuances of what the aristocracy
were and how they operated and so it was
this very specific way of we're us and
you're them and we create these
arbitrary rules to keep it separate and
the more complicated and the more
limiting those rules are the happier we
are about it nice
i hadn't heard about that don't wear
white
until
i don't even know what it is it's
memorial day and labor day i'm canadian
i don't know yeah so you can't well it
yeah you can't wear it until memorial
day and you can't wear it after labor
day so it's a summer only color white
yeah
okay
somebody told me that this year i was
like what are you talking about what
year is that from
when did that stop being a thing is it
still a thing
i well it depends i mean if you're up in
new england if you're up at montauk or
something that's still a thing but for
the for most of the rest of us not
really and that was just that was what
like rich people knew about
there was arbitrary rules that they
created to separate the old wealth from
the new wealth
interesting
so you can find out what all those rules
are and then copy them sneak your way
and
and whether you like it or not
you exist in a world that has those
rules if you work at facebook you have
rules like that you don't show up to
work in a suit you get laughed out of
the room
you well it doesn't matter where you
work or what you do if you go to
your landscaping job and you're wearing
something that's a little bit too skinny
or it's a little bit too high quality
and they're gonna poke fun of you
they're gonna they're gonna and so you
get this men intuitively get this
because we're constantly evaluating the
heart the hierarchy and ever since we
were teenagers we've understood that
clothing is a part of it
and
what i want men to to start to do
is do that more intentionally as opposed
to reactionally or reactively
you think this has a lot like you paying
attention to style like this do you
think this has a lot to do with
personality versus people who are like
nah i don't care this is comfortable
um i think to some extent it does um
and you know if you kind of like to nerd
out on social dynamics or if you like to
understand how people work i think to a
large extent being
more in like the refined or the rakish
archetypes you're going to have more of
a propensity to go this way because it
does fall so much within understanding
dynamics and human interaction and all
of that
uh what i would argue though is for the
vast majority of men who just kind of oh
i don't care
you challenge them to do something like
okay wear a pink dress for the next week
and tell me if you don't feel different
and tell me if you actually don't care
but for them
the the caring is in the not caring
their antipathy is just as emotional of
a reaction to their clothing as somebody
else's affinity to it is and very few
men actually have a true indifference to
what their appearance is
and i would argue that it's not even
about what
you care about it's about how society
perceives you and you don't have a lot
of control over that so you can say oh
this doesn't matter this is my style but
it's going to deeply affect everything
you do
totally and so why why handicap yourself
when you can use it to your advantage
instead
yeah it's like life hacks these things
and it's crazy and i remember reading
about marilyn monroe and she said she
because she had her an insane style
right with her hair and her winged
eyeliner and her lipstick she had
something really serious going on
and she said she could
just turn that off she just dressed in a
completely different way nobody would
recognize her
right so it's like have you seen zoe de
chanel without bangs or glasses like you
don't even recognize her right
yeah
yeah and it's the whole idea of clark
kent in superman and the only difference
is he's in a suit and he has glasses on
in the little curly coif is gone and
that's it but it really we get so used
to seeing people certain ways that it
does become a different identity as soon
as you start to change it
yeah and i suppose for people who are
interested in like i talked to robert
greene recently and he does the art of
seduction that was a really fun
conversation
uh if you're interested in how to like
maneuver your way in social situations
and conversations and what you should
say and how you should act then you
should also be interested very
interested in how you look
absolutely and he obviously understands
that i mean you look at like the 48 laws
of power and you look at men like
napoleon or washington or machiavelli
and
how much these men understood the
importance of appearance washington i'm
going through a biography on him right
now it's insane the amount of time and
energy that he put into not only his
appearance but that of his whole
household and even that of his troops
because he understood the value of it
not only in the social dynamics but also
in the self-perception component too so
yeah that wouldn't surprise me at all
that green would understand that that's
very interesting i bet that
corresponds because i was thinking maybe
it's extroversion i like personality
but maybe it's extra virgin you wanting
to fit in or pick up on other people but
maybe it's also conscientiousness
yeah yeah
cool
cool okay tanner where can people find
you online if they want more help do you
uh do you get clients specifically do
you do this online
yep yep so if you want to reach out to
me uh the best place to be able to kind
of
find me and connect us through uh social
media i'm most active on twitter and
instagram and it's at tanner guzzy so
t-a-n-n-e-r-g-u-z-y
uh the main site that you can look me up
on is
masculine-style.com and that's where you
can look at more coaching and all of
that and then also i've published a book
on this called the appearance of power
and you can find that on amazon and
we've got an audible version of it uh
kindle paperback all of that so if you
want to kind of well you know cut your
teeth on the general concepts that's a
really good place to start but i love
being able to chat with people online my
dms are open and so uh come come talk to
me on there i do a lot of this stuff
especially on instagram to showcase what
a lot of these principles are because i
know with the conversation like this a
lot of this can can sound kind of heady
and it's a whole lot easier to
understand these concepts when i'm
showing visual examples and so twitter
and instagram are really good places to
start to see more of that okay
thank you very much for coming on that
was interesting
thanks for having me on i loved it
[Music]
you